by the way it is turning out that you
are a great actor uh I heard in the
Weird Al movie which I'm anxious to
watch because weird I'm a big weird
outfit yeah I like Weird Al I think he's
just a really peculiar I've had him on
the show a few times he's an interesting
guy yeah but uh the Weird Al movie has
gotten some great reviews but you are
getting raised because you play uh Andy
Warwick yeah yeah I think I have not
seen this the wig the wig did most the
work uh it's one of those things where I
don't do film projects uh Weird Al asked
me to do this so I did it shortly after
my late night show we end well we
wrapped it up I did it was one of the
first things I did so it was a while ago
and so I guess this is what people in
the what it's like to be in movies
everything I've ever done in my life has
been I come in here I talk to you it
goes right out I make a show it goes out
an hour later that's my whole life and
show business I shoot this thing I I
forgot that I did it and I started
getting texts from people saying hey
liked you in the Weird Al move like
friends of mine right and I'm thinking
wait a minute I'm in the Weird Al movie
yeah yeah like a year and a half ago
whatever it was I shot this thing and I
have no memory of it how does he know to
ask you to do that had he seen you doing
a a an impression I think he didn't no I
think he didn't care how good it was he
just wanted to have some wacky cameos so
I do not think I was chosen for my
acting ability but I think he just
wanted to get a couple of and he got
some really fun cameos so Conan can it
become stifling in a career when you get
as famous as you are and you've had so
much success
some So Weird Al asks you to be a little
part in his movie right do you how much
angst do you go through wouldn't it be
very freeing to just say yeah I'll do it
but don't you do you ever go through
that thing like hey I just can't go be
in the Weird Al movie I gotta make sure
this thing isn't a piece of [ __ ] I don't
want to be rich you know what I decided
I've decided first of all it's it's
Weird Al and I you know creatively
thought like this is going to be good
and Daniel Radcliffe is playing Weird Al
and like this seemed like a cool thing
you know you sometimes people approach
you with something and you're like this
sounds very questionable uh this sounded
really good and then you didn't ask to
see the script no now I didn't know
anything when I showed up I just and
that's another thing I'm trying to do
now is I mean I've you know talked to
you many times about uh you know the
years and years and years of going to
Rockefeller Center either with SNL or
the Late Night show and the worry and
the trying to think of everything and
trying to anticipate every problem and
constantly and now uh at this stage in
my life
I want to try things and if it's not
good
uh I apologize you know but I'd like to
I'll give it my best shot and then um
but I don't think that uh
uh I don't know I I think
it's kind of freeing I'm a little I'm a
I'm Freer now than I used to be and I'm
more willing to try things and not over
analyze them